CARLEY: GOOD MORNING, WELCOME
BACK.
RELIEF FOR WORKERS COULD BE ON
THE HORIZON.
LAWMAKERS INCHING CLOSER TO A
BILL THAT WOULD INCLUDE BILLIONS
MORE FOR THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM.
TODD: BUT, AS YOU KNOW BY NOW,
SHOPS AND RESTAURANTS ARE
CLOSING AT DEVASTATING RATES AND
AMERICANS CAN’T WAIT ANY LONGER.
JOINING US WITH MORE ON WHEN
THIS DEAL COULD BE DONE, SENATOR
MARSHA BLACKBURN.
SENATOR, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US ON OUR PROGRAM.
I MEAN, LOOK, YOU HAVE HEARD THE
STORIES, YOU HAVE SEEN THEM ON
OUR AIR AND ELSEWHERE.
PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING.
WHEN IS THIS GOING TO GET DONE?
>> WELL, TODD, YOU’RE RIGHT.
PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING, AND I SEE
IT IN TENNESSEE EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
AS I’M TALKING TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS, AS I’M TALKING TO PEOPLE
IN THE LIVE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY AND BEAR IN MIND THEY
WERE SHUT DOWN OVERNIGHT.
AND WE CONTINUED TO PUSH
FORWARD.
AS YOU KNOW, WE HAVE HAD A BILL
ON THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE TWICE
AND EACH TIME DEMOCRATS HAVE
VOTED IN LOCK STEP AGAINST THAT
FUNDING.
AND THEN YOU HEAR NANCY PELOSI
COME ABOUT AND SAY WELL, NOW
THAT WE’RE GOING TO HAVE A NEW
PRESIDENT, AS SHE IS HOPING,
WHERE IT’S OKAY TO VOTE FOR
FUNDING.
AND HOW TERRIBLE THAT SHE HAS
ADMITTED USING PEOPLE AND THEIR
PLIGHT AS PAWNS IN ORDER TO GET
HER POLITICAL WAY.
I FIND IT TO BE ABSOLUTELY
DISGUSTING.
BUT, WE ARE TRYING TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT.
WE WOULD BE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
DO ANOTHER ROUND OF PPP, PLUS UP
IN UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TO ADD
THAT EXTRA $300 A WEEK.
BEAR IN MIND, PEOPLE LOST THEIR
JOBS THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, MONEY TO
SPEED ALONG THE VACCINES AND
ANTIVIRALS AND THERAPIES.
MONEY TO GET SCHOOLS OPEN
BECAUSE I HEAR IT EVERY DAY.
PEOPLE WANT TO GO BACK TO WORK.
CHILDREN WANT TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL.
CARLEY: YEAH.
WELL, THIS BIPARTISAN BILL
INCLUDES $28 BILLION IN SUPPORT
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND PPP
LOANS WHICH WOULD BE MUCH NEEDED
RELIEF.
CAN YOU SAY WITH CONFIDENCE THAT
SOMETHING IS GOING TO PASS
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR?
>> OH, I CANNOT.
BECAUSE TWICE WE HAVE PUT OUR
LEGISLATION ON THE FLOOR.
WHICH IS THE EXTRA PPP AND THE
PLUS UP IN UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE COULD HAVE HAD THIS DONE TWO
MONTHS AGO.
TWO MONTHS AGO.
AND THINK ABOUT THE IMPACT,
CARLEY, THAT WOULD HAVE ON
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED THAT EXTRA
$300 A WEEK.
BUT, BASICALLY, BECAUSE YOU’VE
GOT CHUCK SCHUMER AND NANCY
PELOSI WHO WOULD RATHER PLAY
POLITICS THAN SOLVE A PROBLEM.
THIS HAS NOT BEEN DONE.
AND IF THEY THINK IT HELPS THEM
POLITICALLY IN RACES IN GEORGIA,
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO DO IT.
THEY ARE GOING TO WAIT AND LET
PEOPLE SUFFER AND, AS I SAID, TO
ME, IT IS ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING.
TODD: IT’S QUITE A SITUATION TO
WATCH FROM AFAR AS YOU SEE THESE
BUSINESSES SUFFERING.
LET US SWITCH GEARS TO OBVIOUSLY
THE BIG TALK OF THE TOWN.
THE FDA MEETING TOMORROW TO
DECIDE IF IT IS GOING TO GRANT
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION FOR,
OF COURSE, THE PFIZER COVID-19
VACCINE.
I MEAN, I THINK A LOT OF
AMERICANS ARE WONDERING WHAT I’M
WONDERING.
IF IT’S AN EMERGENCY, IF WE ARE
LOOKING FOR AN EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION, THE FDA DOES NOT
SEEM TO BE MOVING AT A SPEED
THAT I WOULD CONSIDER ONE YOU
WOULD DO IN AN EMERGENCY.
I HEAR EMERGENCY.
I RUSH, I HUSTLE, DO ALL THAT
SEEMS TO BE TAKING ITS TIME.
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> WHAT I SAY ABOUT THIS IS THIS
IS EXACTLY THE REASON PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP STARTED OPERATION
WARP SPEED.
HE KNEW THAT THE BUREAUCRACY WAS
MOVING TOO SLOWLY TO ADDRESS A
PANDEMIC.
SO HE CALLED ALL OF THE
PHARMACEUTICAL MANUFACTURERS TO
THE WHITE HOUSE AND SAID LET’S
GET IN BEHIND THIS AND GET THE
JOB DONE.
HE PUT THE OPERATION WARP SPEED
PROJECT IN PLACE.
THIS IS A MEDICAL MARVEL THAT IN
THIS SHORT PERIOD OF TIME WE
HAVE NOT ONE, BUT TWO VACCINES
THAT ARE READY FOR APPROVAL THAT
WE HAVE ANTIVIRALS AND
THERAPIES.
WE HAVE VACCINES THREE AND FOUR
IN THE PIPELINE THAT ARE GOING
TO BE CLOSE BEHIND THIS.
AND IT HAPPENED BECAUSE HE TOOK
AN ACTION.
HE MADE A DECISION.
HE SAID WE’RE GOING TO DO THIS.
I REMIND YOU THAT BACK IN 2010,
WITH BARACK OBAMA AND JOE BIDEN,
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN HE HAD THIS
THE BIRD FLU H1N1 THEY WENT FROM
APRIL TO OCTOBER BEFORE THEY
DECLARED IT A PANDEMIC,
60 MILLION AMERICANS WERE
INFECTED WHILE IT WAS MUCH LESS
DEADLY STILL YOU HAD AMERICANS
SUFFER BECAUSE IT TOOK THEM SIX
MONTHS TO MAKE UP -- THIS IS A
DIFFERENCE IN A PRESIDENT THAT
TAKES ACTION AND A PRESIDENT
THAT WANTS TO MOVE THINGS TO
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION.
TODD: MEANTIME, SENATOR, LET’S
SWITCH GEARS AGAIN YOU ARE
GETTING INTO THE PODCAST GAME
WITH A PODCAST CALLED FREEDOM
RINGS.
TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> OH, YES.
EVERY TIME I WOULD BE ACROSS IN
TENNESSEE, PEOPLE WOULD SAY
MARCIA, TELL ME ABOUT SOME OF
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE REALLY
FIGHTING FOR US.
SO, WE DECIDED TO START A
PODCAST CALLED "FREEDOM RINGS."
PEOPLE CAN GO TO FREEDOM RINGS
PODCAST DOT OKAY OR GO TO MY
POLITICAL WEBSITE MARSHA
BLACKBURN AND FIND OUT MORE AT
VOTE MARCIA.
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS PULL
TOGETHER SOME OF THESE HAPPY
WARRIOR FREEDOM FIGHTERS.
KELLY LOEFFLER, SENATOR RICK
SCOTT, THEY ARE TELLING THEIR
STORIES ABOUT HOW THEY GRAY UP